let me just tell you something right now
like you said you're going to be a cat
mom no I'm saying I'm not saying I'm
going to be I'm saying there's women
like that is that what you're on the
right now and not only that women sense
lesbians is that what you want genuinely
I'm not trying to be aggressive do you
want to be a cat mom rapper
you talk about your contribution to
society it's dropping a rap song having
an Instagram like where your tits are
out and then having some cats is that
what you want what you think women do is
that I haven't seen your Instagram
motherhood that's probably what that's
the only value you see in a woman the
only thing that I'm asking you remember
I'm saying the only thing the only value
that a woman has in your eyes is
motherhood so everyone that's the most
important for every woman you get with
as long as she has kids she's valuable
no but is that what you're trying to say
the highest contribution to society a
woman has his mother so what's the
what's the highest contribution that man
has
invent build and maintain Society